foreign
[Music]
box today we are checking out the new
Nvidia GeForce RTX 4070ti formerly known
as the unlaunched 12 gigabyte RTX 4080
in terms of specifications that means
the 12 gigabyte 4080 which is now no
longer and 4070 TI are the exact same
product but thankfully Nvidia hasn't
simply changed the name and just called
it a day we're also getting a 100 US
discount dropping the price from 900 to
800 so that's nice at least if true man
more on that later today's sponsor spot
is brought to you by thermal Grizzly and
their new 12th gen CPU contact frame by
debauer it's well known that the
integrated loading mechanism or ilm of
the LJ 1700 sockets Benz 12th gen CPUs
leading to an uneven contact surface
that reduces cooling performance solving
this issue the contact frame replaces
the ilm allowing for a much more even
contact with the cpu's IHS and the base
of your cooler which in turn reduces
operating 10 temperatures installations
quick and easy and thanks to the use of
anodized aluminum the contact frame is
non-conductive and then for those of you
who wish to further maximize contact
thermal Grizzly now offers an optional
lapping tool so for more information
please check the link in the video
description
okay so let's go over some quick
specifications before we jump into the
benchmarks when compared to the RTX 4080
the MSRP has been slashed by 33 which is
great news that should make the 4072i
the best value GeForce 40 series product
yet based on the ad 104 silicon there's
7680 Cuda cores just 21 fewer than that
of the 4080 but they are clocked four
percent higher then we see a 25
reduction to the L2 cache capacity and a
25 reduction in vram with slightly
slower 21 gigabits per second memory on
a 192-bit wide memory bus and that sees
bandwidth cut down by 30 to 504
gigabytes per second
we're also looking at a modest 11
reduction in total board power with a
rating of 285 watts and other than that
Nvidia is still using the tsmc four
nanometer process and of course though
using pcie 4.0 times 16 for the
interface now there's not a found
Edition model of the 4070 CI instead
Nvidia is letting their board Partners
handle the board design and on here for
testing we have a number of models from
gigabyte MSI and Asus which we will look
at a bit later on for now let's go over
the test system specs and then jump into
the blue bar graphs for testing the CPU
used is the ryzen 7 5800x3d with 32
gigabytes of dual rank dual Channel ddr4
3200cl14 memory on the MSI MPG x570s
carbon Max Wi-Fi motherboard in total
I've tested 16 games at 1440p and 4K so
let's get into the data
starting with the Watchdogs Legion
results we see that at 1440p the 4072i
is comparable to the 6950 XT with 146
FPS on average and that's certainly not
a poor result as it does make it 11
faster than the 3090 TI and just five
percent slower than the 4080 though of
course we are CPU limited here
moving to four case or the 4072i
trailing the 7900 XT by 12 for what was
again a 6950 XT light performance and
really 39 ETI light performance as well
perhaps more importantly though it was
just 19 slower than the RTX 4080 which
is nice given that it is 33 more
affordable or at least it should be
moving on to the Callisto protocol here
the 4070 TI pumped out 122 FPS which did
make it quite a bit slower than the 1700
XT 17 slower in fact using this example
at 1440p I should also note that this
game does enable fsr2 by default with
the ultra quality preset so that's why
it's enabled here this isn't something
that we've manually changed
moving to 4K sees the 4070 TI delivering
6900 XT performance making it just eight
percent slower than the 6800 XT which is
a bit rough given that that GPU can be
had for under 600 right now it was also
interesting to see the 407 HR trailing
the 4080 by a massive 30 margin so these
test conditions were not at all
favorable for nvidia's new alleged 800
GPU
next up we have Forza Horizon 5 and here
the 4072i performed exceptionally well
at 1440p trailing the 4080 by a mere
four percent margin to come in ahead of
the 700 XT by a 13 margin this also made
it 25 faster than nvidia's previous
generation Flagship the RTX 390 ti so
that's obviously a great result
performance at 4K became more
competitive with the 700 XT closing in
but even so the 4070 show was still six
percent faster with 104 FPS on average
and that also made it just 11 slower
than the RTX 4080.
Rainbow Six extraction has some very
competitive results for us with the 700
XT and 4070 TI delivering almost
identical results I'd say this is a good
result for the 4072i as it not only
matched its Radeon competition but it
also beat the previous generations
Flagship by a five percent margin and
was just 19 slower than the 4080. the
3092 I did nudge ahead at 4K but even so
the 4072i still matched the 7900 XT and
even at 23 slower than the 4080 that is
still a good result
the Far Cry 6 performance isn't amazing
at least at 1440p here we're looking at
30 90 light performance so a little
slower than the 3090 TI still we are
quite heavily CPU limited so these
results aren't terribly useful for
high-end gpus jumping up to the 4K
resolution shows just how system limited
the 4K data was that said the 4072i is
still demonstrating 30 90 39 ETI levels
of performance making it 20 slower than
the 7900 XT and RTX 4080
the Assassin's Creed Valhalla results
are much of the same at 1440p were again
faced with previous generation Flagship
performance just two percent slower than
the 650 XT and five percent faster than
the 390 TI that said although it was
just 12 sold in the RTX 48 it was also
13 slower than the 7900 XT and even at
the 4K resolution the 4070 TI still
trailed the 700 XT by an 11 margin with
85 FPS opposed to 96 FPS still that
meant it was just 15 sold on the RTX
4080 thanks to 1390 TI light performance
here we see the 4070 TI is spitting at
193 FPS at 1440 pen hunt Showdown which
surprise surprise meant it was
delivering previous generation Flagship
performance it was also just seven
percent slower than the 7900 XT so
pretty good given that it is meant to be
11 cheaper at least at MSRP we're also
looking at similar margins at the 4K
resolution here it was eight percent
slower than the 7900 XT and again we're
looking at similar performance to that
of the 3090 and here that meant it was
26 slower than the RTX 4080.
the outer World uses the Unreal Engine 4
and this title heavily favors Nvidia GPU
so unsurprisingly here the 4070 TI was
able to nudge ahead of the 700 XT with
167 FPS on average unsurprisingly that
also placed it alongside the RTX 3090
it's a similar story at 4K here the
4072i was a mere two percent faster than
the 700 XT and just 2 slow on the RTX
3090 while it trailed the RTX 4080 by a
23 margin
now unlock the outer worlds Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 doesn't favor GeForce
gpus in fact quite the opposite here the
1700 XT is a massive 32 fast and the 40
70 chart 1440p despite the 4072i being
just seven percent slower than the 4080.
interestingly even at 4K the 4072r is
just 10 slower than the 4080 but also 21
slower than the 7900 XT and as you'd
expect we're looking at previous
generation Flagship performance so given
the price I'd say that's a decent result
The Hitman 3 Performance is very similar
between the 7900 XT and 40 72 1440p
placing both just behind the 3090 TI and
just 11 slower than the 4080 thanks to a
CPU bottleneck the 4072i did fall behind
the 7900 XT at 4K trailing by a 12
margin with 122 FPS on average though
that did also make it just 14 slower
than the RTX 4080.
Horizon zero Dawn's another title where
the 7900 XT and 4070 TI are neck and
neck at least at 1440p where both
provided 30 90 TI and 6900 XT light
performance the 4K data is very similar
again the 47 inchei and 1700 XT are
comparable and again provided very
similar performance that of previous
generation flagships
next up we have f122 and this game has
been tested with Ray tracing enabled as
that's the default setting using the
ultra high quality preset this does hand
the 4072 iron Advantage enabling it to
best the 1700 XT by an 8 margin at 1440p
once again providing RTX 3090 light
performance the 4K results are quite
similar eight percent faster than the
7900 XT and just five percent slower
than the 3090 TI it was also just 19
slow in the RTX 4080 so overall an
excellent result given the price
cyberpunk 2077 hasn't been tested with
rt enabled though I do have those
results and we'll get to them shortly
for now we just have the high preset
enabled with any upscaling features
disabled again the 4072i Matched the
3090 TI and 6950 XT which in this
example made it 10 slower than the 7900
XT then at 4K the 4072 I did struggle a
bit with just 49 FPS on average and
while that is again previous generation
Flagship performance it was also 17
slower than the 7900 XT
moving on to Dying Light 2 we find
fairly competitive results as here the
4072i was just five percent slower than
the 7900 XT upping the resolution though
to 4K does see the 4072i fall well down
our graph with 50 ifps on average just a
few frames faster than the 6800 XT which
is a disappointing result despite being
11 slower than the 7900 XT
the Halo infinite results are
interesting and as seen previously this
isn't a tile that runs particularly well
with amd's new rdna 3 gpus the 4070 TI
for example smokes the more expensive
7900 XT by an 18 margin at 1440p and was
also a good bit faster than previous
generation flagships the 4K data is very
different though and we've seen this a
few times now where arduino3 appears to
suffer some kind of driver optimization
issue as a result here the 4070 tire is
just a few percent faster than the 700
XT which is still a great result for
NVIDIA given they've undercut AMD on
pricing for this matchup
last up we have Shadow of the Tomb
Raider an oldie but a goodie and here
the 407 GI knocked the 1700 XT off by a
four percent margin so basically
performance overall was identical at
1440p it's the same story at 4K this
time the 7900 XT did nudge ahead but
overall performance was near enough to
identical meaning both delivered
previous generation Flagship performance
okay so here are the 16 game averages
starting with the 1440p results and as
you'd expect based on everything we just
saw the 4072i is slower than the 7900 XT
though it's only four percent slower
overall so really very similar
performance for these two gpus we're
also looking at a five percent boost on
average over the 3090 TI and 6950 XT
with a 13 increase over the 1600xt and
RTX 3090 the 4072i was also just 16
slower than the 4080 on average though
in a number of instances we were quite
heavily CPU limited so let's move on to
check out the 4K results
here the 4070 TI was seven percent
slower than the 7900 XT and three
percent slower than the 3090 TI but also
four percent faster than the 650 XT so
in short previous generation Flagship
performance for what should be 800 which
again in today's market doesn't seem all
that bad
it was also 20 slower than the RTX 4080
which again given the price or the MSRP
that does seem quite reasonable
finally for those of you interested
here's the 1080p data when paired with
the 5800 X 3D the 700 XT and 4070 TI are
neck and neck just eight percent slower
than the 4080 thanks to the more CPU
limited testing
okay time for some Ray tracing
benchmarks and we'll start with f122
which we've already tested with rtfx
enabled but here we're looking at how
the 4072i and 1700 XT compare with and
without RT enabled along with FSR and
dlss upscaling in short the 4070 TI is
eight percent faster than the 700 XT
when using Road tracing but 17 slower
with it disabled
now as seen previously when testing with
watchdog's Legion with raytracing
disabled the 4072i was 12 slower than
the 7900 XT however with the ultra rtfx
enabled the 407 HR is now 10 faster so
while the 700 XT is decent here with
raytracing enabled the GeForce GPU does
get handed the win the 4070 TI and 1700
XT were neck and neck and Marvel's
Guardians of the Galaxy using the ultra
quality preset at 1440p without
roadtracing enabled both with around 190
FPS on average however with Ray tracing
enabled the 407 hi is now 25 faster
rendering an impressive 105 FPS
the fortnite results are really
interesting because here we're no longer
using the RT implementation but rather
the Unreal Engine 5.1 so software-based
Ray tracing in my opinion Nano and Lumen
are the most impressive rendering
Technologies I've seen implemented in a
video game for a very very long time and
the rtfx on display here are easily some
of the best I've seen if not the best
I've seen and it's in fortnite of all
games I know crazy
what's just as amazing is how well
optimized these nanoi and Lumen
Technologies are for GeForce and Radeon
gpus with the 7900 XT actually
outperforming the 39 ETI and 4070 TI by
a slim margin so it's very possible for
future games that are built on the
Unreal Engine 5 that will see amd's poor
Ray tracing performance become a thing
of the past
do maternals an RTX titles so no
upscaling for Radeon gpus here but
despite that the game plays at extremely
high frame rates at Native 1440p and
here the 4072 was again slightly slower
than the 1700 XT with Ray tracing
enabled still with around 300 FPS with
basically maxed out visuals at 1440p the
margins here are irrelevant
Resident Evil Village is not an RTX
title so no dlss support here just FSR
though sadly the FSR support hasn't been
updated from its initial release so FSR
1.0 anyway the game does support Ray
tracing and while far from a game
changer and significantly less
impressive than what we see in fortnite
for example it does still for the most
part enhance the visual look of the game
as you'd expect the performance hit is
quite large especially for the 1700xt
but with rt enabled all of the gpus
tested here pushed well above what's
required to enjoy the game the 4072i for
example pumped out 172 FPS on average
and although that made it nine percent
slower than the 1700 XT when using Ray
tracing the performance overall was more
than sufficient and would allow Gamers
to push up to the 4K resolution if
desired now Marvel's Spider-Man
remastered is an interesting title and
we have some odd results here which I
believe are caused by the use of the
ryzen 750rx 3D processor firstly the
GeForce gpus so the 40 72 and 4080 are
limited to just over 100 FPS with Ray
tracing enabled the one percent lows of
the 4080 are higher than that of the
4070gi but both are clearly artificially
limited and this is most obvious when
looking at the 3090 TI which was faster
than even the 4080 and this wasn't just
the case with rt enabled even with rt
disabled the 309 ETI was still 14 faster
than the 4080. so that's odd to say the
least and as a result I did remove
Spider-Man remastered from our day one
RTX 4090 review noting a strange driver
bug that limited performance of the 4090
to around 100 FPS but this now seems to
be less of a bug and just an overhead
issue with the 4D series or some
particular issue with this game whatever
the case though these results are
accurate with the
5800x3d that means with that RT enabled
the 1700 XT is 16 fast and the 4070s
show and with it enabled performance is
much the same
the cyberpunk 2077 Ray tracing
performance even with the high quality
preset is brutal and even the 4072i
really does require some kind of
upscaling Technology As It produced just
51 FPS on average still that made it 46
faster than the 700 XT which managed
just 35 FPS and even with the help of
FSR 2.1 versus dlss for the 4070 TI the
GeForce GPU was still 47 faster so a
very easy win here for NVIDIA
finally here's a look at the average Ray
tracing performance scene across the
eight games just looked at and please
note I've grayed out the upscaling
results as the data here isn't Apples to
Apples and in some games the Radeon gpus
didn't even receive upscaling support
what's interesting to note here is that
the 7900 XT sorry 54 decline in
performance with Ray tracing enabled
while the 4070 TI only saw a 43 decline
yet overall the ray tracing performance
was much the same between these two gpus
the 4070 TI was an average seven percent
faster with Ray tracing and then 13
slower with Ray tracing disabled now if
we were to ignore the RTX titles where
Radeon gpus typically get decimated and
decimated by designer might add the ray
tracing performance of the 7900 XT
actually looks pretty good I think
titles like fortnite for example so
therefore I believe moving forward the
RT battle is going to be a lot less
one-sided it's probably not good news
for NVIDIA
as we've already seen when testing the
RTX 4090 and 4080 nvidia's Ada Lovelace
architecture is very efficient and we're
seeing yet another example of this with
the 4070 TI testing and Dying Light 2
shows the 4072i pushing total system
consumption at just 357 Watts a 15 power
saving when compared to the 7900 XT
moreover the 40 70 chart was comparable
to the RX 6800 and RTX 3070 so an
impressive result given the performance
the Doom Eternal results are also
interesting as here the 700 XT and 4072i
are much similar When comparing total
system usage both pushing over 400 watts
which is still very reasonable we're
also looking at fairly similar power
usage in Hitman 3 the 700 XT push total
system uses just six percent higher and
was just two percent slower when looking
at frame rate performance so the 4070 TI
was clearly the more efficient GPU but
in this example they are really very
similar
now with the frame rate locked to 90 FPS
we see the 4072i is the most efficient
of the current generation gpus released
thus far pushing total system usage to
347 Watts three percent less than that
of the RTX 4080 and 18 less than the
7900 XT
now for the all-important cost per frame
analysis we'll start with the MSRP data
if all current and previous generation
gpus were to be sold at the suggested
retail price the 4072i would actually
represent fairly good value it's
certainly not amazing don't get me wrong
only roughly matching the RTX 3070 and
6800 XT the previous generation sensible
options let's say but that's not exactly
a bad result when compared to its most
direct competitor so the 7900 XT the
4072i costs around four percent less per
frame while offering Superior Ray
tracing performance and dlss support So
a clear win here for NVIDIA no matter
which way you slice it now when
factoring in the current retail pricing
the 4070 TI still Stacks up reasonably
well despite costing four percent more
per frame than the 7900 XTX though it is
four percent cheaper than the 7900 XT
now assuming that you can buy the 470 TI
for 800 which certainly isn't a given at
least over the next few months anyway
but let's just say you can it would be a
massive 21 discount per frame from the
current RTX 4080 asking price even at
the MSRP the 4070 TI's cost per frame
represents 16 greater value than that of
the 4080. so Nvidia really has corrected
pricing here and they absolutely needed
to if they don't want these things just
sitting on shelves like a lot of RTX
4080s are
now all of the results you've seen in
this video have been based on the
gigabyte Eagle version of the 4070 TI
and here's a look at how that model
behaves after an hour of load when
installed inside an ATX case at a 21
degree ambient room temperature the
eagle peaked at a hot spot temperature
of just 70 degrees with a peak average
GPU temperature of 61 degrees and then
the memory peaked at 64 degrees so a
cool running card and impressively the
fans were spinning at just shy of 1800
RPM to achieve these results
we also saw a core clock frequency of
2820 megahertz with the memory clocked
at 21 gigabits per second so this is the
default or stock behavior for the 4070
TI as the eagle model adheres to the
Nvidia spec that is to say there is no
Factory overclocking here
now the aorus master on the other hand
that is an overclocked 4072i though not
exactly a big overclock we're looking at
a one and a half percent frequency boost
in Hitman 3 hitting
2865 megahertz it was also disappointing
to find that this massive cooler didn't
really improve temperatures by a
noteworthy margin the auris Masters are
a peak GPU hotspot temperature of just
69 degrees a degree cooler than the
eagle while the memory Peak to 56
degrees so good Improvement for the
memory though 64 degrees same with the
eagle was plenty cool for the memory
we also have MSI Supreme X and this
model wasn't that impressive at least
not as impressive as I'd hoped it would
be firstly for whatever reason MSI ships
their premium graphics cards with the
silent bias as the default setting
whereas Asus and gigabyte use their
performance bios by default anyway for
this testing I'm using msi's performance
bars so these results aren't based on
the silent Buffs even so we ended up
with a hotspot temperature of 76 degrees
which I've got to say is very
disappointing as that is six degrees
hotter than gigabytes base model the
memory also peaked at 76 degrees which
is a massive 12 degree increase over the
eagle and worse still we're looking at a
fan speed of 1700 RPM so in terms of
operating volume the supremax eagle
lenorous Master are all very similar now
the Supreme X typically operated its
course at 2850 megahertz which is a
little higher than that of the eagle but
lower than the aorus master so nothing
special there power usage was also
similar so perhaps the supremax cooler
isn't contacting the GPU die as well as
it could be but whatever the case the
results are a little disappointing
despite being acceptable
the Asus tough gaming also reached a
peacock spot temperature of 77 degrees
but it did so at a relatively low fan
speed of just 1500 RPM and was therefore
silent or at least quieter than our case
fans the memory peaked at 76 degrees are
the same temperature as the supremax and
we're looking at a typical operating
frequency of 2835 megahertz so an
acceptable result for a more base model
let's say and it is worth note the tough
gaming 40 70 chart is substantially
smaller and lighter than the aorus
master and supreme X and I've got to say
I much prefer the look and build quality
of the Asus tough gaming when compared
to the gigabyte Eagle namely because
that is an all-metal fan shroud opposed
to an all-plastic design of the gigabyte
card but both models share the same
dimensions and there really is no
denying that you do get a better cooler
with the eagle so gigabyte has done an
amazing job with their base model so
what to make of the GeForce RTX 4070 TI
then well as with all of these next
generation gpus from AMD Nvidia I'm not
really Blown Away by what's on offer
here even if we ignore current retail
pricing for previous generation hardware
and just focus on the suggested retail
pricing the 4072i doesn't really move
the needle forward the cost per frame so
the value it offers is no different to
the RTX 3070 yeah you're getting around
60 more performance as shown in our
testing but at the MSRP you're also
paying 60 more and this was the issue
with nvidia's Turing generation in terms
of value it offered nothing over Pascal
unless you're bought into the lie that
dlss and Ray tracing we're going to
redefine gaming back in 2018 of course
neither of them did and even today
largely fall short of such bold claims
therefore like the Radeon RX 7900 XTX
the GeForce 4070 TI it's a fine product
but it comes with an uninspiring price
tag whereas the 7900 XTX should cost no
more than 900 the 407 TI should cost no
more than seven hundred dollars having
said all of that though a part of me is
very glad Nvidia decided to set the MSRP
at 800 and not the original plan nine
hundred dollars that they announced with
the 12 gigabyte RTX 4080. speaking of
which I'm seriously questioning just how
real this 800 MSRP actually is we know
Nvidia had their sites fixed on 900 for
this silicon and we know Nvidia does
like money we also know MSRP targets
haven't always been met by Nvidia gpus
whether or not Nvidia is to blame is
difficult to say but I'm currently of
the position that I'll believe that you
can buy an RTX 4070 TI for 800 when I
see it
and this is a big problem for our
viewers because at 900 us the 4070 TI is
hot garbage a terrible deal that should
be avoided like a plague as an example
here's a cost per frame graph showing
where the 4072i would be positioned at
900 and frankly this looks to be a bit
more realistic at least what I was
expecting at 900 the 40 70 chart is Dead
on Arrival for just a hundred dollars
more the 7900 XTX absolutely destroys it
and again I don't think the 700 XTX is
great in terms of value
so I'm really hesitant to believe that
the 4072 will be an 800 product and
sadly it'll be at least a month before
we know for sure at which point Supply
will have caught up with the initial
demand I really hope it's not a
situation where we see some 800 listings
for some base models that are just never
in stock and if you want a 47 inch high
realistically you've got to pay more
like 900 I'm also hoping it's not a
situation where even if the MSRP is met
in the US other regions Canada Australia
we just pay so much more for the 4072
that it's just not worth buying and in
some instances you could probably get
something like a 700 XTX for the same
price of course this is yet to be seen
I'm just hoping that this isn't a
situation that we'll be faced with now
moving on as good as the performance of
the 4072 IUS and again I'm not
necessarily talking about how good it is
for the money I just mean in general the
performance was impressive pumping out
87 FPS on average at 4K so as good as
that is I do Wonder just how long it'll
be before 12 gigabytes of vram starts to
become insufficient at this performance
tier for example the most expensive
previous generation GPU from AMD to only
offer a 12 gigabyte vram buffer was the
550 6950 XT though that model quickly
dropped below MSRP so really I'd say
it's the two-year-old 6700 XT at 480 us
so just shy of 500 admittedly though
nvidia's own vram budget for the GeForce
30 series gpus it was just all over the
place but even so the 3080 offered 10
gigabytes of vram two years ago I feel
today at this price point 16 gigabytes
should be the absolute minimum
especially given there are already
numerous examples where eight gigabytes
no longer cuts it at the high end
and no I'm certainly not advocating you
spend nine hundred dollars on the 7900
XT for the extra eight gigabytes of vram
but if AMD were to slash prices and get
the 700 XT to a similar price point to
that of the 4070 TI than it would be in
my opinion the more obvious choice and
on that note the 7900 series pricing by
AMD was so dumb they've somehow once
again managed to make Nvidia look good
and that's because you want to price
your latest and greatest products so
that when they enter the market they're
the obvious choice forcing your
competitor to give up market share or
make a price cut just to compete you
don't want to enter the market and just
roughly match your competitor because
for one where's the incentive to go AMD
worse still if Nvidia were to knock just
a hundred dollars off the 4080s MSRP
that effectively canceled the 7900 XTX
forcing AMD to make a day one price cut
which would look silly as fail failing
to do so would inevitably result in poor
sales in short you want to put your
competitor in a position where they'd
have to reduce prices just to compete
not a position where if they simply
knocked eight percent off you're done
evidently though Nvidia didn't feel
threatened Enough by amd's latest and
greatest offerings to do anything which
is probably the most disappointing
result possible for consumers anyway as
I've said the GeForce 4070 TI is a
perfectly fine product the wow factor
though just simply isn't there as your
face we're having to spend 80 series
money on a 70 series product and I'm
sure some of you will point to inflation
but don't kid yourself these companies
are making out like a bandit overall
margins might be down but they're still
making billions in profits and charging
you at least 800 U.S for a 295
millimeter square die is all part of
their plan to keep the good times
rolling and that is going to do it for
this one if you enjoyed the video do
give it a like subscribe for more
content not sure if we're doing any sort
of partner card roundups for this
particular model I guess it depends on
pricing and whether or not it does turn
out to be
good value relative to what other
options you have we'll wait and see on
that one but yeah
like subscribe patreon float plane if
you're interested in becoming a hardware
box Community member check those out uh
you will get access to exclusive Discord
server monthly live streams Q A's behind
the scene content a lot of cool stuff
there check it out if you're interested
but if not that is perfectly fine
and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Steve
see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign